lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
obtener algo de práctica sobre cómo
estimar el resultado de una división con
decimales por ejemplo queremos encontrar
cuánto es aproximadamente ojo este
símbolo que parece un signo de igual
pero garabateado significa que nuestro
resultado es aproximadamente igual a amp
es decir a que es aproximadamente igual
80 / 1.94 así que queremos estimar el
resultado de esta división pausa el
vídeo e inténtalo
antes de ver las opciones cómo podemos
encontrar la estimación del resultado
mentalmente
bueno dividir 80 entre 1.94 es difícil
de encontrar la solución en nuestra
mente sin embargo si nos damos cuenta de
que 1.94 es muy cercano a 2 entonces
podemos decir que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 80 entre 2 de
nuevo la idea detrás es que 1.94 es
aproximadamente igual a 2 y 80 entre 2
es fácil de encontrar el resultado es de
hecho 40 por lo tanto podemos decir que
la expresión original es aproximadamente
igual a 40 es exactamente igual a 40 no
pero es una buena aproximación entonces
seleccionaremos el inciso b
de lujo hagamos otro ejemplo bien ahora
pausa el vídeo e intenta encontrar a qué
es aproximadamente igual la división de
209 entre 3 en esta ocasión no tenemos
involucrados decimales pero una vez más
si hiciéramos esta división obtendríamos
un resultado con un punto decimal que
sale de un residuo la clave aquí es
pensar en si podemos encontrar un
múltiplo de 3 cercano a 209 que sea
fácil de reconocer bueno puedes pensar
que 3 por 6 es 18 3 por 7 es 21 entonces
3 por 70 es 210 que es bastante cercano
a 209 así que 209 entre 3 es
aproximadamente igual a 210 entre 3 y
porque esto es interesante bueno es
interesante porque 210 entre 3 es 21
veces 10 eso entre 3 o 21 por 10 entre 3
sabemos que 21 entre 307 y entonces 210
entre 370 una vez más 209 es muy cercano
a 210 tanto que podemos decir que una
buena estimación de la división de 209
entre 3 es 70 esto es aproximadamente
igual a 70 y otra vez es el inciso b
hagamos uno más pausa e intente
encontrar a qué es aproximadamente igual
la división de 6.86 entre 1.12
bien aquí intentaremos redondear al
número entero más cercano y vamos a ver
si eso nos ayuda a hacer de una manera
más fácil una buena estimación de esta
división en nuestra mente bueno 6.86 es
aproximadamente igual a 7 entonces será
7 y si redondeo para abajo 1.12 al
entero más cercano pero es simplemente 1
y 7 entre 1 es mucho más sencillo de
hacer que la división original 7 entre 1
es simplemente 7 es importante mencionar
que todo esto son estimaciones esta
división no va a ser exactamente igual a
7 pero es una mejor estimación que 70 o
que 700 o que 7000 piensa en eso hasta
la próxima nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo